INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT THAT
THAT DATE COULD FLIP.
>> Shannon: WILL WAIT AND SEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RUDY GIULIANI SAYS THE SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR'S TEAM IS TRYING TO
FRAME THE PRESIDENT.
GIULIANI MADE THE COMMENT ABOUT
ROBERT MUELLER DURING AN
INTERVIEW IN ISRAEL.
>> A GROUP OF 13 HIGHLY PARTISAN
DEMOCRATS THAT MAKE UP THE
MUELLER TEAM, EXCLUDING HIM, ARE
TRYING VERY, VERY HARD TO FRAME
HIM.
TO GET HIM IN TROUBLE WHEN HE
HASN'T DONE ANYTHING WRONG.
>> Shannon: GIULIANI SAYS THE
MUELLER TEAM CANNOT COME TO
GRIPS WITH THE FACT THAT
COLLUSION DID NOT HAPPEN.
MEMBERS OF THE U.S. HOUSE CAN GO
AHEAD WITH THEIR SUMMER VACATION
PLANS.
THE HOUSE MAJORITY LEADER SAYS
THE AUGUST RECESS IS STILL ON.
EVEN AS SENATORS PLAN TO WORK
THROUGH MOST OF IT.
EXACTLY WHAT THOSE SENATORS WILL
BE WORKING ON, THAT IS STILL
UNDECIDED.
HERE IS CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MIKE EMANUEL.
>> MAJORITY LEADER.
>> MITCH MCCONNELL MAY HAVE
BOUGHT HIMSELF MORE TIME TO
CHECK SOME ITEMS OFF HIS LIST OF
PRIORITIES.
>> WE NEED TO CONFIRM MORE OF
THE PRESIDENTS TEAM AND JUDICIAL
NOMINEES.
WE NEED TO TAKE UP REGULAR
APPROPRIATION BILLS.
WE NEED TO TACKLE LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES LIKE THE WATER AND
FOR STRUCTURE BILL, THE FARM
BILL, DEFENSE BILL AND MANY
OTHERS.
THE SENATE WILL REMAIN IN
SESSION.
>> ONE G.O.P. SENATOR HAS A
PRIORITY OF HIS OWN.
KEEPING PRESIDENT TRUMP'S TRADE
POLICIES IN CHECK.
>> BECAUSE THEY ARE UTILIZING IT
IN THIS UNPRECEDENTED WAY, WE
HAVE ASKED, HOW CAN YOU CONTINUE
THE THINGS.
ONCE YOU COMPLETE THE WORK, YOU
HAVE TO SUBMIT A TEST FOR
APPROVAL BECAUSE TARIFFS AND
REVENUES ARE THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF CONGRESS,
NOT THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
>> DEMOCRATIC LEADER TIPPED HIS
HAT ON HOW HE WANTS TO SPEND
AUGUST NOW THAT THE SENATE IS IN
SESSION.
>> WHY DON'T WE GET SOMETHING
DONE ON THE ISSUE THAT NUMEROUS
POLLS SAY IS THE NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY OF AMERICANS?
HEALTH CARE.
WE DEMOCRATS, OUR ENTIRE CAUCUS,
BELIEVES THIS PREVIOUSLY ON
SCHEDULED SESSION TIME CAN BE
PUT TO GOOD USE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP APPLAUDED
McCONNELL'S CALL, SAYING
"GREAT.
MAYBE THE DEMOCRATS WILL FINALLY
GET SOMETHING DONE OTHER THAN
THEIR ACCEPTANCE OF HIGH CRIME
AND HIGH TAXES."
HIS PRAISE MAY HAVE FALLEN ON
DEAF EARS WITH KEVIN McCARTHY
WHO SAID HE HAS NO PLANS TO KEEP
THE HOUSE OPEN, TELLING
REPORTERS I UNDERSTAND WHY THE
SENATE NEEDS TO FINISH THEIR
WORK.
WE HAVE BEEN DOING OUR WORK.
THE MAN WHOSE JOB McCARTHY IS
EYEING WANTS TO THREAD THE
NEEDLE ON THE ISSUE THAT
THREATENS TO DERAIL THE G.O.P.
>> I FEEL GOOD ABOUT THE KIND OF
CONVERSATIONS WE ARE HAVING.
OUR MEMBERS ARE EARNEST AND
SINCERE IN TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
EACH OTHER'S PERSPECTIVES.
WE HAVE A BIG, BIG SWAP OF VIEWS
IN THE CONFERENCE.
I DO BELIEVE THERE'S A SWEET
SPOT.
>> TO BE CLEAR, McCARTHY IS
NOT ATTACKING McCONNELL.
HE'S NOTING THAT THE HOUSE THIS
PAST HUNDREDS MORE BILLS, AND HE
BLAMES SENATE DEMOCRATS FOR
OBSTRUCTION.
WITH SOME ITEMS ON THE TO-DO
LIST CONTROVERSIAL, IT MIGHT